for the audience that may not know your
background how you got to where you are
today if you don't mind taking a minute
sharing your background that'd be great
so it's hard to do in a minute but my uh
my father was an anti-communist who
created a secret students organization
in Hungary after the Communists took
over he was betrayed by somebody called
Kim philby a British double agent he was
arrested tortured and given a life
sentence at the age of 20. he was two
years in solitary two years down the
prison coal mine and eventually
liberated by the revolutionaries in
1956. he escaped to the West literally
across a Minefield with the 17 year old
daughter of a fellow political prisoner
who became his wife and my mother I was
raised in the UK two Hungarian parents I
spoke Hungarian as the first language
and then after the war fell I went to
work in the new Hungarian government the
first freely elected Hungarian
Government after communism I worked in
the defense industry in the defense
Ministry helping them get into NATO
because I'd served in the British
reserves in a military intelligence unit
so I was helping them get back into the
West did lived in Hungary for 15 years
met my beautiful American Wife in Europe
and then 9 11 hits and an amazing man a
marine who was a legend one of the
greatest men I've ever known Nick Pratt
Colonel Nick Pratt a former CIA
paramilitary invited me to teach on a
count of terrorism program out of
garmish Pat and Kirk and we have a U.S
base in Germany and I was teaching a
kind of terrorism course for four years
to our allies and our partners and then
um woke up one morning with my wife 2008
we literally looked at each other in bed
we woke up when he said time to go
communism screwed this country it's
going to take another 50 years I applied
for three jobs in the U.S VMI West Point
and National Defense University got a
job at ndu teaching canadaism to 0506s
and one stars and then I wrote a book
called defeating Jihad and somebody
called corally Corey Lewandowski rang me
up in the summer of 15 and said hey uh
Mr Trump would like to meet with you to
get some prep for the GOP debates on
National Security I said uh okay so I
went to Trump Tower sat down with then
Mr Trump for about 40 minutes
unbelievable discussion from the Civil
War to nuclear weapons to Isis to you
name it and then classic Trump move
there's only three of us in the room he
looked at Corey in the corner he said
I like this guy let's hire him so I
became I signed an NDA like Stormy
Daniels me and stormy
yeah
and then I started writing him policy
papers for the debates and then I ended
up in the white house as his Deputy
served there for seven years seven
months felt like seven years
um and then resigned because of certain
things we can discuss later and now I
have a national radio show with Salem
America First in a TV show and uh
Newsmax called the Goku reality check
and I'm loving it I love it so uh the
the the 2008 when you walk up you and
your wife you're like we gotta we gotta
get out of here what was the Tipping
Point for you you know what for me for
me it was one concrete thing so our kids
uh were uh in 2008 when nine and and uh
seven and they spent every summer in the
US because of my wife's family so they
were socialized As Americans I remember
one day they went to the little catholic
uh School in the village where we lived
about half an hour outside of Budapest
and one day I was watching the
playground and I saw this C
of gray kids with their heads down and
not engaging and I see two kids standing
upright looking people in the eye and I
thought wow
our kids are different and and I
realized there's a there's a saying that
is maybe proctorful it's attributed to
uh yanoshkadar who was the creator of
goulash communism this softer kind of
Communism after Stalin died and
apparently somebody asked him in the
pilot Bureau why are you doing these
reforms why why are you slightly
loosening the grip on the people in in
communist Hungary and Kardash said
allegedly I find it much easier to bend
the spine slowly over time than to try
and break it suddenly so this form of of
you know watered-down Communism had so
seeped into the blood that in 2008 I
could still see it in the kids and the
10 year olds and the nine-year-olds and
I said I've done my I've done 15 I'm in
the land of my forefathers I have done
15 years I've investigated the Prime
Minister for being a secret police
officer I've had death threats on my
family I want to live in a country that
I respect and I'd been working with the
US military for about four years and I
said I love these guys I want to work
for them in America and become an
American so that's why so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]